thanks to brilliant for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
go to brilliant.org microcosmos to learn
how you can take your stem skills to the
next level this year
[Music]
every living thing on this planet has
water in them
some may have more than others and some
like our desiccated tardigrade tons
may be able to survive long periods of
time without water
but while those tardigrades may be alive
they're not
quite living they're taking a very
protective nap and they'll wake up only
when water reappears in their life
water's chemical structure is the basis
of life
itself it shapes the interactions of
biological molecules
maintains the shape and structure of
cells and drives reactions that
power our entire world and so
inside each of us is an ocean
and that is why we pee
[Music]
getting rid of waste is a complicated
messy business to untangle and boiling
it all down to a simple matter of
pooping and peeing is doing a disservice
to the variety of organismal junk around
the world
but we are just a humble youtube channel
who has made one episode about how
microbes poop
and so now it feels necessary to give
equal do
to how they pee
the goal whether solid or liquid is the
same
removal there are things in a body that
must
come out but we cannot just wantonly
dump things out
that would be like sweeping any small
item in your house into a trash bag
sure you get rid of some dust but you're
also potentially
throwing your wedding ring into the
dumpster in our bodies
we turn to kidneys to filter out toxins
and ammonia waste
while reabsorbing metabolites what
doesn't get reabsorbed
gets released as urine but even simpler
organisms need to be able to regulate
the water and metabolites inside them
for one water is a physical thing
it takes up space and creates pressure
inside a cell
which is good up until a point
and once you get past that point
organisms can end up
bursting like this poor microbe here
and aside from the terrifying thought
that you could water yourself
into bursting there's the matter of
maintaining the right balance of
life-sustaining molecules and getting
rid of waste
so parameciums and some other
single-celled eukaryotes
rely on a set of organelles called the
contractile vacuole complex
that are connected to the outside
through a pore
the contractile vacuoles go through
cycles of
filling and expelling as the vacuole
fills up with fluid from
inside the organism the pore closes up
keeping everything inside the vacuole
and when that's done
the pore opens back up you know
for the peeing so there are the simple
and effective methods on one end
and the complex organs on the other so
what comes in the middle
well let's take a look at this
asplanchna it looks weird
even for a rotifer and at around half a
millimeter long it's on the large size
for what we normally
see but it's still a microscopic
metazoan
which means that unlike our single
celled eukaryote friends
its body has organs some of these organs
seem
roughly familiar like the aspartana's
stomach
and the space around those organs is not
empty
it's full of fluid giving the rotifer
something
to monitor and regulate for the sake of
its own survival
to do that the asplanchner and other
simple multicellular organisms like it
rely on a structure called the
protonephridian
which begins oddly enough at the end
with a set of hollow cells
called terminal organs in asplanchner or
other similar animals like this
polyarthra those terminal organs are
referred to
as flame cells because of the flickering
movement inside them created by bundles
of cilia
some organisms replace those cilia with
flagella and their terminal organs are
called
selenocytes instead the asplanchner's
flame cells draw in fluids acting
as an initial filter that blocks the
larger molecules from passing through
the cells use their cilia to send the
fluid
down a coiled tube but at that point
there still
might be some important small molecules
that the organism could use in that
mixture
like certain sugars or amino acids and
so
as the fluid travels through the tube
those molecules get selectively
reabsorbed into the rotifer what remains
in the proto-nephridium is the urine
which gets collected in the bladder
drained into the cloaca and then
released
into the world
a fun side note cloacas act as a sort of
multi-purpose opening in the case of the
rotifer
yes it is used for peeing it's also used
for giving birth
so maybe you're swimming in rhoda for
pee or maybe you're swimming in rotifer
babies
whichever one it is it all came from the
same place
as we mentioned other organisms have
proto-nephridia
as well including flat worms some
segmented worms or anilids
also have a proto-nephridium while
others have a metanephridium
the principle is the same they take in
fluid and then modify it to reabsorb
what's
necessary for the organism and remove
what isn't but the metanephridia connect
directly to the worm's cavity through a
ciliated
funnel the remarkable thing about waste
is that
like water we all have to deal with it
it is
every bit as much a part of life as the
living
itself is proof that our bodies
have done something consumed something
made something the only thing more
remarkable
is that even when the basic principles
of waste management stay the same the
end results
can look so different
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore
the unseen world that surrounds us and
thank you again
to brilliant for supporting this video
sure we might have spent the last
several minutes talking to you about
bodily fluids but with brilliant
you can actually learn about the physics
of how toilets flush after you put those
fluids into them
in the course physics of the everyday
you will investigate
everyday physics from household objects
to weather patterns
brilliant has courses about science
engineering
computer science and math and the
courses are designed to be hands-on
with interactive quizzes and guided
problems with explanations
you can access the daily challenges for
free but if you sign up to become a
premium member you'll get access to the
entire archive
and brilliant courses are now available
offline using their ios
and android app so if you're traveling
or have spotty internet connection
you'll be able to keep learning if
you're interested in learning more you
can get 20
off an annual premium subscription at
brilliant.org
microcosmos the people on the screen
right now
these people are our patreon patrons
they make it possible
for us to do this show so if you're
thankful for a nice pee
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
they're the people to thank
if you'd like to join them you can go to
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss
check out jam and germs on instagram and
if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you